a team of experts from the world health
organization
is in wuhan investigating the origins of
the coronavirus
they were released from a two-week
quarantine just a few hours ago
our raymien ancincio was in wuhan during
the initial outbreak and he's back there
now covering the investigation
[Music]
finally free in wuhan to find kovit's
origin
13 experts from the world health
organization liberated after 14 days in
quarantine
they tweeted photos of their departure
new york-based epidemiologist peter
dashak
showed off his clearance letter he told
cbs news
before his release china's first cases
are his focus
what contacts they had what behaviors
they had and does that lead us into
different geography or a different
behavior so it's unclear if china is the
real source the original source of the
virus that will probably frustrate the
many people around the world who believe
covet
did come from china juan on seafood
market thought to be ground zero
the world health organization is
expected to visit but this place has
been cleaned out and shut down ever
since the pandemic started
for the haunan seafood market how does
waiting a year make it tougher for the
who
unless you do hours after incident
you know whether it's a day a week or a
year makes no difference
sars expert wang linfa in singapore is
tracing kobit's origin
and says the market can still offer
clues if they can
really trace back how the cage was
arranged
what animals were sold basically where
you cannot win right if the breacher
could not get a mission to china than to
say you know they are toothless
if they get a mission to china now they
say it's a pr stunt
but polished propaganda is what the
communist party knows well
from a new patriotic documentary for the
nation to a massive coven museum
in wuhan critics have said that
they can't trust china to be forthcoming
with all
the data that they have let history be
the judge and let's be patient on those
issues
and we may need a lot of patience peter
dodjak says it could be at least two
years until we know the origin of covid
but wang linfa says it could be more
than 40 years
based on ebola bottom line guys it could
be a long time until we know and
don't expect any breakthroughs from the
world health organization trip
this time tony all right remy innocencia
once again for us in wuhan remy thank
you very much